foreign
[Music]
over the last few weeks Ethiopian
government has started demolishing
mosques in the oromia region which
borders the the at this region uh the
capital city of Ethiopia there has been
demonstration the Muslim leadership in
the country has responded to it and the
police subsequently has also used live
ammunition against the protesters who
are saying that they cannot continue uh
sitting idle by while the government
destroys their places of worship
okay
the reason or the argument is some of
these mosques have been on illegal lands
and therefore they need to go for us to
do proper urban planning they are
talking of large-scale infrastructure
expansion including roads
and so therefore for the community they
look at this as a displacement from the
place that where they worship
foreign
[Music]
inside Ethiopia over the last century it
was largely between the aromos and the
national government which is the federal
government in artists they are the
largest ethnic group author of the
population who feel that they are not
being represented
the problem can be resolved the question
is is there a political will within the
oromia government and the federal
government to be able to do that this is
a constituency that you do not want to
alien it it is a serious breach of
Rights of individuals otherwise we are
opening another front for conflict
inside Ethiopia
foreign
[Music]